hi I'm Patti Kim we're taking off for
Egypt and one of the most extraordinary
sites in the world the Pyramids at Giza
just outside Cairo built to honour the
ancient Egyptian rulers these iconic
pyramids attract thousands of people
every day
now the crowds can be a little bit
overwhelming so here are a few tips to
make your trip as hassle-free and is
amazing as it ought to be for over 4,000
years the Pyramids at Giza have
attracted visitors with their size
grandeur and mystery many secrets about
these magnificent structures remain
built to its day and eternity they seem
in no hurry to reveal them to the
ancient Egyptians the pyramids were both
tombs and individual units within a vast
temple network they were holy sites
tended by royal priests built to
safeguard the worldly remains of the
Pharaohs from Thebes and transport them
into the afterlife the largest the Great
Pyramid of Khufu today stands almost 450
feet tall thousands of workers labored
to build the Pyramid for the pharaoh
Khufu who reigned about 2,500 BC over 2
million stone blocks were used each
averaging about two and a half tons
despite its size experts believe it took
perhaps only 20 years to complete the
middle pyramid the tomb of the Pharaoh
Khafre is guarded by the Great Sphinx
which stands near the pyramids causeway
carved out of a single block of
limestone the 240 footlong statue
combines the body of a lion and the head
of a man most likely the face of the
Pharaoh Khafre himself
the last of the three great pyramids is
the tomb of the Pharaoh men Caray many
other tombs and temples are packed into
this massive necropolis which is still a
working archeological dig here
scientists continue to make new
discoveries that add to our knowledge of
ancient Egypt many tombs are open for
the public to view with hieroglyphs and
carved reliefs depicting ancient
Egyptian life if you're willing to make
steep climbs and navigate tight corners
you can even explore the passageways of
the Great Pyramid tickets to venture
inside are limited to 300 people per day
so show up early if you want the Grand
Tour the site itself is just outside of
Cairo and is easily accessible by taxi
or bus to avoid the crowds arrive in the
early morning or early evening staying
late also has its advantages find a good
vantage point and you can watch the
sunset over the pyramids it's a site
that's been inspiring visitors for over
4,000 years